y aquí tenemos el vector w y pueden ver
en este diagrama que su punto inicial
está aquí en menos 73 su punto final es
este de aquí dos menos uno lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es pensar en cuál es
la magnitud de nuestro vector y a qué me
refiero con magnitud una forma de pensar
en esto es cuál es la longitud de este
vector qué tan largo es pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo con base en
la información que nos dan algo que
pueden notar es que la magnitud del
vector es en realidad la distancia entre
estos dos puntos por lo que si quieren
la magnitud simplemente tienen que
aplicar la fórmula de la distancia que
es el teorema de pitágoras lo que
podemos hacer es construir un triángulo
rectángulo la altura la ponemos en rojo
y será nuestro cambio en g y en azul
vamos a poner nuestra base que es el
cambio en x sabemos por el teorema de
pitágoras que la longitud de la
hipotenusa que es la magnitud de nuestro
vector es igual a la raíz cuadrada de
nuestro cambio mx
al cuadrado más nuestro cambio en g al
cuadrado a que será igual esto veamos a
que es igual nuestro cambio en x podemos
verlo como nuestra x final
- nuestra x inicial que es 2 menos 7
negativo y es igual a 9 positivo esto es
9 al cuadrado y nuestro cambio en g es
nuestra final que es menos 1 menos
nuestra ley inicial que es 3 esto es
igual a menos 4 aquí bajamos 4 unidades
esto es igual a menos 4 nuestra magnitud
va a ser igual a la raíz cuadrada de 9
al cuadrado que es 81 más menos 4 al
cuadrado que es 16 esto a que va a ser
igual le sumamos 6 81 y nos da 87 más
bien nos da 97 es la raíz cuadrada de 97
creo que no podemos simplificar más esto
pero para darnos una idea de su valor
podemos decir que esto es casi igual a
la raíz cuadrada de 100 por lo que el
número será un poco menor a 10 esta será
la magnitud de éste
en este caso pudimos calcular la
magnitud usando sus puntos iniciales y
finales otra forma en la que podemos
especificar un vector es si nos dan un
componente x y un componente y por
ejemplo en esta situación podemos
definir nuestro vector w como la suma de
dos vectores uno de los cuales es el
componente x este es el componente x de
w y este otro es el componente de w que
estoy dibujando aquí podemos ver que el
componente i es igual a nuestro cambio
en g y que el componente x es igual a
nuestro cambio en x así que a veces
verán algo así el vector w es igual a
estas podrían parecer coordenadas pero
en realidad nos están dando los
componentes el componente x es 9
positivo y el componente que es menos 4
albert esto podrían decir que conocen
los componentes xy pero no saben dónde
comienza y dónde termina el vector esto
es a propósito porque en un vector solo
nos interesa su magnitud y su dirección
y aquí especificamos ambos
si queremos conocer la magnitud de aquí
tomamos la raíz cuadrada de la suma de
los cuadrados de estas magnitudes de
nuevo la raíz cuadrada de 9 al cuadrado
más menos 4 al cuadrado será la raíz
cuadrada de 97 nos interesa la magnitud
y la dirección del vector pero podemos
desplazarlo todo lo que queramos este
vector w
podría comenzar aquí y abarcar 9
unidades en la dirección x y menos 4
unidades en la dirección y por lo que
luce así podemos desplazar los vectores
como queramos lo que nos interesa es la
magnitud y la dirección y espero que con
esto tengan un mejor entendimiento sobre
cómo calcular la magnitud usando los
componentes o usando los puntos de
inicio y fin y con esto terminamos